[音楽]
を将来失明すると
ある日突然医師に言われたら
皆さんはどんなことを考えますか
お好きな方が読めないのかな
仕事はどうすよ
旅行には行けないのかな
さまざまな不安が頭をよぎるかもしれませ
ん
こんにちはイシノ宮ケ沢です
私には10代の頃にとても仲の良い友達が
いました
彼はカメラマンを目指し日々活動を続けて
活動的な彼があるしたまたま寄った眼科で
将来失明する病気を持っていることを医師
に告げられました
その数実後彼は自ら命を絶ち
帰らぬ人となりました
彼の命を奪ったのは
失明する事実
それよりも
自らの夢を奪われた
そんな鉄棒の闇なのかもしれません
事実毎年何名かの患者が失明宣告を受けた
その数実以内に亡くなると言います
私の友人や
私の患者達を
死へと追いやる
絶望の闇はどこから来るのか
そんなことを私は
あの日からずっと考えてきました
あれから20数年
人の夢を奪う絶望の闇はどこから生まれる
のか
私なりの答えは
思い込みの病であるということでした
見えなくなったら
治らない病気になったら
もう何もできない
私の人生は終わりだ
そう思い込んでしまう
そのことこそが病気なのだと思います
医療が進み
我々は以前よりも長く人生を過ごすように
なります
そのような中で
見えにくい
聞こえにくい
さまざまなソースと共に生きていくとも
言えます
失うことが大
できなくなることであるという思い込み
それをなくすための
夢の処方箋
それが私の医療です
今日は皆さんに私が行っている
夢医療と私がデザインした
夢病院について紹介したいと思います
私の外来では
女に不自由がある患者や
読み書きに不自由がある患者に
ipad や iphone などといっ
たテクノロジーの使い方を紹介しています
ある患者にタブレットの背面カメラを使っ
て
書籍を拡大して見ることで読書が楽になり
ますよと紹介しました
ところが彼女は私の貸し出したタブレット
を使って
独唱するのではなく罪が切れるようになっ
たと喜んで帰ってきました
爪が切れたら自分でマニキュアが濡れた
またおしゃれなデートができる
彼女が外に出られなかったのは目が悪い
からではなかったようです
我々医師が病院で行う検査の結果には表示
されない
見えないことからくる多くの困りごとや
その元になる彼ら彼女らの想い
その存在を患者達は日々私に教えてくれ
ます
医学の専門家であり
目の病気に詳しいがあまり
患者のことをよく理解しているという
思い込み
そんな思い込みが病から日々患者たちは私
を救ってくれているのです
私がまだ大学生だった頃
授業でこんな言葉を習いました
患者は教科書である
その意図は
実際の患者さんを診ることで座学ではまだ
不こともできない
病気の症状や治療効果を学べるそんな人
だったのかもしれません
しかし私の経験を通しては患者に学ぶべき
ことは
病気の症状だけではなく
病から来る生きづらさ
つまり
見えにくさというものが生む
困難さにあります
患者は
病気や医療を教える対象であると同時に
我々木シガー
患者から学ぶ対象でもある
そんな気づきが私の思い込みという病を一
つ外してくれました
このような経験を通して私は患者から学ぶ
というスタイルの医療を始めることにした
のです
治る病気の患者に必要なのは正しい診断と
治療ですが
治らない病気にかかった患者に必要なもの
はなんでしょうか
私がそれは夢ではないかと思っています
印刷物が読めないなど
かつては目でしかできなかったことが現在
ではスマホのカメラを通して
ai や遠く離れた親切な人が代わりに見
てくれるなど
そんなことが簡単にできる時代になりまし
た
私の外来で目の難病にかかり
数年で説明した方向性は帰り道にこんな
手紙をくれました
僕の将来はずっと明るい
この時代に生まれて本当に良かったです
事実の進行は医療よりも早く
大切なことはこういったテクノロジーの
存在を知っていること
そしてなによりも
見えないこととできないことが同じでは
ない
そのことに気づくことなどではない
でしょうか
私の病院にはさまざまな年齢の患者が訪れ
ますが
先日
生き生きとした90代の女性が ipad
を駆使して必死に体が切れ手紙を書こうと
していました
私がつい自分の好奇心を抑えられなくなり
彼女に聞いてみました
なぜそこまでして体勝ちにこだわるのか
彼女はフッと笑って私のニュー下でこう
囁きました
実は若い彼ができたの
どうやら市域といるためには
恋する心というスパイスが必要なようです
失うべきでないのは視力異常に好奇心や
こういう心なのかもしれません
患者を揺らすのは医療ですが
私の夢の病院では患者さんに患者を処方し
ます
そんな不思議な夢病院が出来るまでの物語
を紹介します
皆さんちょっと目を閉じてみてください
イメージです
ここは病院
そして皆さんは病室のベッドで横になって
います
長く続くムチ砂白い壁
そして病室を除くのぞき窓
看護婦さんが患者のリストを持って夜の
巡回をしています
どうですか
ここで社会的なつながりや生きる希望を
もらえそうですか
けがや病気は治りそうですがあまり長くは
いたくないように感じますよね
なぜ病院では病気が治っても人が元気に
なれないのでしょうか
ではもう一度目を閉じて想像してみて
ください
ここは最果ての地
世界一厳しい
刑務所の牢獄です
皆さんは牢獄の中で横たわっています
看守が牢獄ののぞき窓を見て回っています
あれ
特価さっきと似ているように感じませんか
ところで病院の目的ってなんでしょうか
それは安全に患者の治療を行うことです
では刑務所の目的は
安全に罪人を管理することです
この2つの施設
どこかにでいるように感じてしまうのは私
だけでしょうか
病院に行くと病気になるそんな冗談があり
ます
でも多くの人がそう感じる理由は
アルコール消毒の日本のせいでしょうか
利用者よりも管理者のニーズを中心に設計
された建物
そんな歴史もその理由のひとつかもしれ
ません
どうして病院に行くと現地がなくなるのか
私の夢の病院がそんな素朴な疑問から
始まりました
一般的な病院のデザインにおいては段差は
視覚障害者にとって危険なものであり排除
すべき存在です
しかし私は段差って本当に危険なだけ
だろうか
段差がくれる成長や気づき学びはないのか
そんなことを考えていました
そんなあるし患者が私に
こんなことを教えてくれました
彼女は家の近くに帰ると白杖をしまうのだ
と
ハクゾウとは視覚障害者が移動する際に
使う白い杖
薄情により視覚障害者は段差を安全に移動
することができます
しかし家の近くで白杖を持つことが障害児
のシンボルになる
それが心の抵抗を生むというのです
我々がなくすべきは
物理的な段差以上に白杖を人前で持ちたく
ないという心理的な壁や偏見ではないかと
気付かされました
そこで見える人も見えない人もう
薄情みんな当たり前のように使うことで
段差を中心に対話が生まれたり成長が
生まれる
そんな空間作りをはじめよう
逆転的な発想から私の夢病院のデザインは
具体化を帯びていきます
夢病院が完成して3年
失明宣告を受けた患者にとって
一番の希望となったのは自分と同じ病を
持つ患者が市域と病院の壁でクライミング
をする姿でした
私たちの夢病院の壁は光と音で目が悪くて
も登れるクライミングを茹でてきています
ん
夢の病院では元気な患者を処方します
その目的は元気な患者と出会う場を作る
ことです
ある患者が帰り際にこんな言葉をくれまし
た
今日はいっぱい勇気をもらった楽しかった
です
また遊びに来ますね
私は患者に手を振りながらほんの少しだけ
思い込みの病を治せるようになった気がし
ました
彼女の病気の名前は
私の友人が診断された病気と同じだった
からです
最後に治らない病気にかかった1人目の
患者の話をさせてください
私は手術2にてが増えるという
外科医としては致命的な障害を持ってい
ました
1人目の患者は私自身です
今から10年前
外科医として限界を感じる中で友人の命を
奪った病気の治療法が見つからず
私は絶望の日々を過ごしていました
そんな中で東北地方を襲った大きな地支援
震災は私に人生の時間が有限であることを
強く思い出させてくれました
そんな時に私は一人の医師と出会いました
医師の名前はパッチアダムス
パッチアダムスは笑顔が患者を救うと信じ
て
患者がは患者を見る夢の病院を作った
ドクターです
私は彼に出会うことでもう一度
なぜ医者になりたかったのかを思い出す
ことができました
私は外科医になりたかったのではなく
パッチアダムスのように患者と向き合い夢
と希望を処方する医者になれなかったの
です
彼との出会いが
私を要求を治す医者から
患者の心を癒し
生きる喜びを共に見つける
そんなドクターに変えてくれました
私には夢があります
いつか私の人生が終わるその日
人生お先に走りきってしまった私の友人に
再会し行ってあげたい言葉があるんです
見えなくなっても大丈夫だよ
思い込みの病はもう消えた
今でも私は手が震えるその癖は直ってい
ません
しかしこのことは私の人生にとって大きな
意味はないようです
今日の私の物語が皆さんが思い込みの病
から逃れる
最初の一歩になることを祈っています